what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to explain every armor titan
in the history of attack on titan in my
opinion this shifter is severely
underrated
because not only does it have thick
armor covering its body but it also
grants the user a substantial amount of
plot armor as well
this special pot armor has allowed
reiner to survive for nearly four whole
seasons as we're making this video
i mean even when he genuinely wants to
die the plot still finds a way to keep
him alive
before we begin i should mention that
although reiner has had his armor broken
many times over the years
this is still one of the most durable
titans out there the armor enabled him
to save zeke's life during the battle of
forced lava
as well as easily obliterating the gate
in war maria
and defending against the blades of the
survey corps when we contrast this with
other titan shifters
the warhammer is the only one that's
really comparable as it has a thin white
shell protecting its body
it's hard for me to factually say which
of these has better protection
because we just haven't seen the warmer
tested enough for example we haven't
seen how the warhammer fares against
cannon fire or
swords whereas with the armor titan we
have kind of seen a lot of different
case studies
i would say though that both of their
armors were broken by thunderspears
so i mean i guess it is true that
humanity is surpassing the power of the
titans
anyway as usual for this type of video
i'll be explaining the backstory of the
armor titan
that we properly know and then
commenting on the unique designs of the
ancient armor titans
this is the fourth video i've done in
this series after previously doing every
beast titan
warhammer titan and draw titan so be
sure to hit the sub button if you
haven't already
and let me know in the comments which
one you think i should do next
okay so the first armor titan we're
going to talk about is rhino braun
who's a guy that was never meant to get
this titan in the first place
starting at the beginning he is the
illegitimate son of karina braun and a
random malia man
who wanted nothing to do with them as
reina grew up in the internment zone of
liberio
he spent most of his childhood
desperately trying to become a warrior
because warriors are granted the title
of honorary malian citizens
he believed that his mother and father
would be able to live together once he
acquired that
title because as a young child karina
implied that the only thing stopping
them from being a family
was the fact they weren't malians reiner
persevered in his attempt to become a
warrior candidate but could only watch
on as marcel bertolt annie and the rest
of them
were all chosen ahead of him the problem
for rhino was that he had no practical
skills that put him above any of those
kids
but he was eventually chosen as the
final warrior candidate
after displaying a frightening loyalty
to mali in the written tests
this over-the-top loyalty is something
that was definitely inherited from his
mother
and as we saw in the anime poco
absolutely roasted him for it
of the seven warrior candidates at the
time one of these two was meant to
inherit the armored titan
and based on merit it would have been
galilead but as we know
poco was sabotaged by his brother
marcel's interference is the only reason
why rhino became the armored titan
and who knows i mean history would have
changed completely because maybe the
mission on paris would have been
successful like we don't actually know
anyway as i was alluding to rhino was
one of the four warriors selected to
infiltrate parity's island
with zeke and peak staying behind in
mali this was meant to be a happy moment
for rainer
as one of his other goals for becoming a
warrior was that he wanted to be a hero
that could save the world
this mission to parodies provided him
with exactly that opportunity
but there were a few things that kind of
soured the mood reason number one was
that he had an encounter with his father
before he went to the island
where his dad made it clear that
reiner's existence was pretty much the
biggest mistake of his life
i imagine it wasn't the pep talk that
rhino was expecting to receive
but things managed to get even worse
once he arrived on the island
as the warriors gathered around the
campfire marcel revealed the truth
that reiner was never meant to be chosen
as a warrior and it was only because of
his actions that it happened
before anyone could even really process
the information yamir's pure titan
appeared out of nowhere as the sun began
to rise
and if it wasn't for the plot armor
titan then he definitely would have died
in this moment
in all seriousness though clearly marcel
already felt some guilt about you know
making
rainer become a warrior instead of his
brother which is no doubt why he was so
quick to save him from being eaten
with this one event the warriors had
lost one of marley's seven titans
on the very first day of their mission
and annie argued that they should count
their losses and return home rhino was
majorly opposed to that idea
partly because he knew he'd be eaten
straight away if they returned to mali
because marcel died to save his life
it's not far-fetched to assume that the
military would hold ryan responsible
and therefore if that was the case porco
would be ready and available to eat the
armored titan
on top of that rhino still had his own
ambition to be a hero that people could
respect and that was only possible if
they continued with the mission
through his desperation he was able to
convince annie and bertolt to persevere
with the plan
and later that same day they arrived at
wool maria with rainer personally
smashing the inner gate
it was really cool to witness the scene
again in season 4 because that time
around we were able to hear his inner
thoughts as either underneath this
terrifying titan
was actually just a confused child who
was at the beginning of his journey
now in terms of the design his armor
titan stands at around 50 meters tall
and with the exception of some minor
areas his entire body is covered in
armored plates
the front of his neck is one of those
exposed areas but luckily his nape has
two protruding bits of hardening that
protect his human body
well most of the time it has an armored
mouth guard that opens in an almost
mechanical way
and as is often the case with some
titans its short blonde hair was
identical to its user
being a trained warrior candidate rhino
was able to use this titan in very
interesting ways
such as selectively destroying parts of
his armor to increase his speed
or hardening his fingers that he was
able to scale the walls of parodies
despite that i say advances in
technology have affected this titan more
than any other
as the armor is its main selling point
obviously but it can't withstand
anti-titan artillery or thunderspears
when you consider that titans have been
around for 2000 years
rhino almost certainly had it the worst
out of any armor titan because
the tech in this era is really making
him obsolete
one last thing to say about rhino
specifically is that according to
bertolt
neither of them could remember the
memories of their predecessors so as of
making this video we don't know exactly
who had this titan before
rhino next up we're now going to be
looking at all of the ancient armor
titans that existed throughout history
but bear in mind that some of these
images are from the final arc of attack
on titan
so if you don't want to know spoilers
then pause the video now
the first ancient titan we should talk
about is this guy who is covered from
head to toe in relatively small plates
of hardening
to me this design must have been
inspired by the thing from the fantastic
four
as isayama has never been afraid to take
inspiration from western media
for example rhino's armor titan was
modeled after brock lesnar
and in the manga there was a pure titan
designed after saul goodman from
breaking bad
with the exception of its neck area the
thing has no areas where it's not
covered by armor
so who knows this may just be the most
armored armored titan in history
moving on chapter 137 was the debut of
this ancient armor titan who we saw
rugby tackling another titan shifter
it has curved armor on its face which
looks pretty awesome alongside its hair
and unlike rhino it has no mouth guards
so its teeth are completely exposed
the helmeted armor titan is next and as
the name i gave it suggests
its defining feature is the medieval
style helmet on its head
because the back of the helmet is shaped
like this it means the nape area is
protected by both the regular armor
on the back and the helmet as well so i
imagine that trying to kill this guy
would have been incredibly hard
the one downside of this whole design
though is that there's a lot of bare
flesh exposed on his face
but beyond that it looks pretty good
another ancient shifter was this freak
of nature over here which is a strong
contender for the grossest looking
armored titan
it has a bunch of clumpy hardening
around the side of his head and the
hardening around his eyebrows and
forehead was also quite bizarre
in the manga we saw it engage in combat
with both humans and other titans but
ultimately was decapitated
with a swift kick going back to the very
first armored titan to ever exist
we got this guy here whose design is
remarkably similar to rhino's
in all honesty the only noticeable
difference between him and reiner
is this gap in between his chest plates
but beyond that they are basically the
same
in this panel on the left it kind of
looks like it has a mouth guard as well
which you know only furthers the
comparisons
the remaining armor titans in this video
only had fleeting appearances
such as this guy who had armor around
his torso and head but no protection on
his arms and this one here with the
strange pattern on his forehead
not to mention this one here that i
think might be an armored titan though
i'm not 100 sure because
the coloring makes it look pink but i
think it still might be an armored
potentially
there was also this one here in the
background that didn't really have any
outstanding features that caught my
attention
but i thought i'd put it in here just so
you can see as of making this video the
attack on titan manga still has two more
chapters to go
so in theory there could still be
another armored titan if not many more
to come
but right now i'm also kind of
entertaining the idea that maybe
after the series is done there will be
no more titans i think that's a
possibility as well given what the
founder can do
so we'll just have to see thanks for
watching as always and be sure to let me
know down below
which titan you think i should do next a
lot of people in my last video were
asking me to do the armor titan so now
that i've done it i am kind of
interested to see
what's going to be the next most popular
until the next one peace out